Elite hostility to people of faith
that's the subject of tonight's angle in
the aftermath of the church massacre in
Texas all of us were outraged and
heartbroken across social media
politicians and concerned Americans
everywhere remembered the victims and
offered the grieving families of
Sutherland Springs their thoughts and
prayers but almost immediately
celebrities and certain media types
rushed to ridicule and demean that
religious sentiment actor Michael McKean
in a tweet wrote they were in church
they had the prayer shot right out of
them maybe try something else
Stephen King whose Dark Tower series
features a gunslinger he tweeted enough
with praying time to start legislating
the hostility to faith infects the
popular culture there is militant
secularism moving throughout the country
that not only disparages people of faith
but targets them because of it
entertainment and media elites
caricature people like those in that
church in Sutherland Springs as
intolerant backwood yeah whose their
bible thumpers when they're actually
among the best of America they may not
be the fancy people out on the red
carpets or in the gym with their
personal trainers but when the chips are
down and help is needed they'll put
their own lives on the line
pick up a long-gone if needed and go
save their neighbors if you pay close
attention these elites are not only
trying to politicize this tragedy but
they're disparaging the faith of the
people killed in those pews actor Wil
Wheaton responding to speaker Paul
Ryan's call for prayer he wrote the
murdered victims were in a church
if prayers it anything that still be
alive you worthless sack of so prayer is
incapable of doing anything hmm
what if they were having brunch at the
peninsula hotel with their managers they
might still be here is that your point
will
no wonder he spells his name with only
one L it's William two L's the
intolerance of religion it's penetrated
every corner of the culture when
esteemed Notre Dame Law Professor Amy
Barrett was nominated to the Seventh
Circuit Court of Appeals
she was grilled by Democratic senators
not really for her legal reasoning not
so much but for her Catholic faith dick
Durbin asked if she considered herself
an Orthodox Catholic he didn't mention
that she has seven children but he might
as well have Senator Dianne Feinstein
went even further she suggested that
quote the dogma lives loudly within you
and that's a concern can you imagine
either of those senators trying that on
a Muslim Court nominee oh no they
wouldn't
despite the religious hazing Barrett was
confirmed last week good this is an
intimidation campaign that has been
tried and tried again even on yours
truly I didn't even know about this by
the way until a few days ago but
following the debut of this show last
week a bright light at something called
The Observer calm dubbed me the church
lady church lady was pretty funny by the
way because I quote appeared before the
audience in purple vestments that's a
dress by the way that highlighted the
gleaming girl gold cross on my chest
here it is it's really powerful ah as
expected the cross hating author is a
former New York Times employee and a
segment producer for Keith Olbermann
figures last week a high school football
coach in Georgia was told that he can't
participate in any student initiated or
student-led prayer before or after or
during a football game so he can't pray
at all in his official capacity as a
coach the Coweta County School Board
directive came only after the Freedom
From Religion Foundation filed a
complaint you see the atheists aren't
happy
unless they're trampling on another
person's religious liberty
we'd better be very careful remember
the Declaration of Independence ever
heard of it we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal and that they are endowed by their
creator with certain unalienable rights
among them life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness our natural rights are not
dependent on the government but on God
that is what undergirds this country and
frankly what sustains us and for those
of you who don't agree you're in my
thoughts and prayers get over it
that's the angle